sound a much better day at the office
for you two victories with the white
pieces the first one in great style
against linear but this one was a big
one yeah
better today yesterday than today but I
scored less points like I usually could
have made two and a half or three
yesterday and today I think I was quite
lucky to make two points I mean the win
with Lanier was very very smooth yeah
but between rounds two and three I don't
really believe I deserve 1.02 in these
games probably half a point would have
been fair I was probably a bit too
adventurous against Wesley I suspect I
was fine at some point and been here
with Hikaru uh obviously I should never
have won this game that has to be about
the starting position because this is
the whole so I was working with Sam
Sabian today I just I've said this
before I just believe he's the best guy
to go to for the uh specifically for the
start official random games he's the one
who plays the most fish around he's
really good at it so and this was the
one we were the most struggling with and
so I just couldn't figure out how I
wanted to coordinate the pieces right
and then I really only decided like
right at the board to play D4 we had
looked at C4 E4 F3 but like none of it
was really and I think Sam Actually
played F4 if I'm not I I can't start
with him as well this we were not we I
thought this was reasonable that F6 was
the move we were struggling dealing with
and I thought black was fine there I
guess Ray played D5 and just gave the
pawn but D5 after like five minutes of
thinking yeah no maybe I should have
played F4 just to get uh to get Hikaru
out of comfort zone because very quickly
I disliked my position like here I just
realized I'm in a bad Banker but I
didn't think I have a huge choice in the
matter
um yeah and it should be a bit worse but
I didn't think it was the end of the
world like akara told me after the game
he thought I was like basically lost
which
is felt like a little bit of an
exaggeration I definitely think the
opening went badly wrong for me but I
mean right now it's equal it didn't seem
that terrible I thought it's I couldn't
coordinate the pieces decently well it's
easy forever lost
um it doesn't seem like you were ever
lost it says I'm better even that I
wasn't right it was 95 good there I was
thinking about it but I wasn't sure how
to evaluate this position so Knight
takes D5 let's say
and then what is it no txd5 Bishop D5
Bishop D5 Rook A1 and C4 and this one I
was struggling to evaluate
it's not quite fast enough to coordinate
right yeah yeah yeah I thought about
this but something guys
yeah okay so around here I mean I still
thought my position wasn't great
apparently I was wrong but uh yeah
um and then I think the critical moment
I thought was when he played Knight A4 I
was very surprised by this move I guess
the computer says it's fine but it
really feels like it's begging for
trouble and why is that oh there's like
I mean just okay so after Bishop C5 like
he could have taken enough to enforce me
to take with the rook and self pin like
a second ago and then I can and here you
know he can check on A1 or whatever I
was like
Black's clearly fine and the only
question is can he play for a win night
I forged I took one look at it it felt
wrong I couldn't find like anything
busting it but there were some funny
lines like for example Bishop C5 yeah
this is fine knight dc5 uh
F5 quinter2 is also possible there and
here for example like yeah Queen D2 and
Knight D3 I guess holds together right
is the point
yes okay so that didn't work so I had to
play F takes E5 and here for example
after Queen takes C3 do you take C5 I
don't know if akara saw this but Knight
takes E5 exists and it's very important
that after fe5 Bishop C4 black has 96 in
a shotgun V6 uh which Saves the Day for
him I didn't even think this was about
after 25 but which is not yeah it seems
to be very close to equality but the way
I played I thought was totally
reasonable as well like we got this end
game and then I had to choose between I
thought what I did was the most popular
because I could also play 95 instead of
Bishop takes F7
um but I didn't think it was as
coordinating as well you know Rook A4 is
a good move and black is fine Rook E4 is
quite important though yeah so I played
but I found this bishop of seven King F7
and B4 which is very well timed because
the note does not have a great place to
go to and I'm sure the computer holds
this but this does not look trivial
tonight at all no I mean those b-pawns
are incredibly scary and all it takes is
one bad move and like I mean how many
moves did it take for him to be lost
how does he save it after B6 King B5 and
then Knight A5 what's Rook d8 online
okay so he needed to find only moves
already and this I missed of course so I
guess if you go but even this like I
mean after Rook to you what is his next
move he cannot play King B6 Rook D6
should be no the king is close enough to
the outside pass Pawn I guess perhaps
yeah okay because he cannot play King B4
either so I guess yeah okay he's making
a draw on the pawn ending I mean that's
like
picaro's as good as anyone like finding
this stuff with zero seconds on his
clock but this still feels impossible
yeah okay so that was the way and then
he misses that in the game's over I mean
so if I'm not wrong
yes now he's just dead right he's over
yeah yeah this is all twos you know yep
yeah so decent day I mean obviously yeah
it would have been nicer if I had beaten
serving at the end of yesterday and then
um
uh also I was much better with Iranian
declined a repetition and lost but so I
felt yesterday so I got unlucky and
today I got lucky so yeah bounces up how
do you get ready for a tournament like
this and what's the most important skill
I guess you have to perform during the
game
to get the best positions and the best
results I I think that honestly the best
thing I did was just realize that savian
was the guy to talk to I think that's a
huge step in the right direction
um but no like I did note preparation
chess wise whatsoever for this
tournament I was just been focusing on
other stuff like I have U.S Championship
coming up but I wanted to make sure I
was full of energy so just you know
exercise a lot like really this
tournament has everything to do with
form and energy levels and nothing to do
with preparation so I just wanted to
make sure that I came in with a lot of
energy well Sam still three rounds to go
a lot to play for we'll see you tomorrow
thank you